[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans question de
campagne aujourd'hui pour parler d'un
des thèmes principaux de la campagne de
lionel jospin présider autrement nous
recevons mademoiselle céline qu est
céline code bonjour bonjour vous avez 27
ans vous êtes médecin et vous souhaitez
poser une question et une aile jospin
oui tout à fait et puis début de la
campagne n'osent pas nous dit qu'il veut
présider autrement mais un président de
la république est élu pour exercer une
fonction bien précise
alors concrètement présider autrement ça
veut dire quoi
nous lui avons posé votre question à son
atelier de campagne écoutons sa réponse
ça veut dire d'abord un véritable
engagement comme candidat les
propositions qui sont les miennes je les
mettrai en oeuvre
je donne ma parole aux français je n'en
change pas selon les moments où les
publics
ils savent que cette parole je la
respecterai aux responsabilités avec le
gouvernement je les écouterai je serai
au milieu d'eux mais je leur dirai aussi
comment vivre ensemble fraternellement
et quel rôle donné à la france dans
l'europe et dans le monde
une élection présidentielle c'est le
moment d'obtenir des réponses claires et
précises aux questions que se posent
tous nos citoyens
aujourd'hui une question de monsieur
foulatier de rennes monsieur jospin
allez vous revoir oui ou non le statut
pénal du président de la république
écoutons sa réponse assurément oui merci
de nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt
pour un prochain rendez-vous de
questions de campagne
[Musique]